Hey guys, I'm Nate, welcome back to the workshop
We love having comment requests from you guys for ideas of what we should do and we have a request here from Matthew DeRossett
Matthew asks what happens if you put whipped cream or beaten egg whites in a vacuum chamber
would they turn back into regular cream and egg whites respectively
well Matthew we think that's an excellent question so today we're going to try out both of those things
We'll take some heavy cream and turn that into whipped cream, then we'll take some egg whites and beat that until we have a meringue
Then we'll see what happens if we pull as much air out as we can and see if they return to their regular
un-whipped state. Let's start by whipping up some cream
Most of the time when you're making whipped cream you do add sugar to it to make it taste a little sweeter, but because we
want to see if our whipping cream returns to normal after being whipped,
inflated, and deflated in a vacuum chamber, I'm not going to add any sugar to this one
so we can see how close it is to the regular unchanged whipping cream
There we have it, we have our whipped cream and a bowl and it has been filled with air to the point that it is
no longer even a liquid. Now let's take some of this, scoop it off
into our vacuum chamber, and see what happens when we depressurize
whipped cream
I'm not really sure how much of this to put in. I don't know how much it will expand, and I don't want to go
so high that I have to turn off the vacuum pump
Let's try starting with just a nice little glob not the whole bowl full, and see what happens when we depressurize it
It's alive~ That's certainly growing quite a bit. Oh
boy, it still might be too much
That was enough to fill the whole chamber all the way
Several times
Wow I thought the cake batter expanded a lot. It's got nothing on this
That's gonna work so cool when we add food coloring
Think that it just started to break before I
opened the valve a little that last time
There we go
Well that looks kind of disgusting in there right now
Doesn't look like whipped cream, and it doesn't look like un-whipped cream
It's just sort of this mass of- it looks kind of like plastic sheets got melted onto the walls
Guess I'll turn it off
Open this up and let some pressure back in
There we go, repressurized
First impressions, I'm gonna say that has not turned back into regular whipping cream. I don't know what that is,
but it's not regular whipping cream
All right so when I have a larger
amount, of it together on the spatula it is a little more liquid. Definitely more liquid than whipped cream
Tastes about the same
Unsurprisingly
Um-
I feel like some of the milk fat may have started to change form, not so much that it started turning into butter,
but something is different about it see what happens if I just scrape all of it as much as I can
into sort of one spot
Give it an opportunity to cool a little bit
All right, we do have a liquid here. It looks like it's still
maybe a little thicker than
just
normal cream. I'm wondering if there's still some air in it, and now that we've gathered it all in one spot,
we can pull more out. So let's try turning the vacuum chamber back on and
sucking any additional remaining air out of our little pool of cream. Here goes.
So it is expanding, so there's definitely still some air inside that blob
in fact it's expanding quite a bit, so I guess there is a lot of air still inside that blob.
It's tough to suck all of the air out of something
Oh, it's gross
well it's still bubbling and popping a lot, and I kind of want to just let it run until
that bubbling and popping is mostly stopped, because I think that's when we'll have most of the air pulled out of our cream
If it takes too long though, I'm just gonna turn it off
All right, this is still bubbling-
at about the same rate as it was like, three minutes ago. I think at this point we're just boiling the liquid
inside the cream so let's just let the pressure out, and see how liquidy our cream has returned to being.
Stops bubbling as soon as I turn it off. I haven't even put any pressure back in but as soon as I turned off the vacuum
it stopped bubbling
Oh look at that, it's running
Already running as a liquid. Y'know I think that looks pretty much just like cream. We may have done it, we may have just
returned whipped cream to an un-whipped state
It tastes like cream. It looks like cream.
Well that's really cool. But my favorite part of that is how much the whipped cream expanded, and we didn't really get
to see
Its full potential because this container is too small. so let's try using the larger jar, and
maybe a tiny bit less whipped cream and see if we can still get a tiny bit of cream to fill the whole jar it
looked like it was about to do that
And that's awesome
There we go, I've got a little cup full of our whipped cream. Now let's add just a little bit of food coloring because I
think this will be even cooler in color. Let's just add a couple of drops of red and gently mix it in
Alright, three
The larger chamber of course, does take longer to depressurize, so it's gonna go a little bit slower, but it's definitely growing
Is it gonna break? Is it gonna break?
Aughhhhhhh
I have to add- Nope, nope. I didn't add any pressure back! That was it. It's like hollow on the inside of this, it's just completely
GONE
That was great
That was great~ look at this
That was the most expansive thing we've ever put in a vacuum chamber, I'm pretty sure. I thought the cake batter was good, this
well, it takes the cake
Takes the cake from cake. That was beautiful.
I'm touched. Alright, let's add pressure back in and see what happens
Didn't change a whole lot
Yep, that's sort of creamy. It's a little bit liquid. I bet we could combine this together and pull out a little bit more air
But we've already tried that. We know what happens. Now I just want to see more whipped cream expanding. Let's try more colors
Alright. Here goes- marbled yellow and blue whipped cream
And.. plop. Falls to the bottom. That's great
Delightful. There you have it, whipped cream in a vacuum chamber. When you pull out all the air, it actually does a pretty good job
of
returning to normal cream. It seems like it's about the same consistency, it tastes the same, so I think that one kind of works
Now let's try the same experiment using whipped egg whites, also known as meringue
There we go,
Egg whites from six eggs. I don't make meringue much, so I don't know how much it's gonna make. I feel like it's gonna
be way more than I need. Guess we'll find out
Alright, we're gonna call that good. I think they might actually be able to beat even more till they're even
more full of air and a little bit stiffer and shinier but
I'm also pretty sure that egg whites can break if you beat it too much and since I am not a baking expert, I
don't want it to break and have to start over. So right now it's pretty stiff, it's not very liquid
We're gonna try this, I bet it'll work really well
Now the egg whites did expand more than the whipping cream, so I'm kind of wondering if they're going
to do the same thing in the vacuum chamber. I almost want to start with an even smaller amount of the meringue
Yeah, let's just try about this much- see how it turns out. Alright, here goes
And it is growing
And it's holding a shape. It kind of looks like a little ghost or something, like, "I'm a big ghost now~" I
can see some bubbles on the surface starting to pop already
Broken. Nowhere near the expansion of the whipped-cream
So while it had a lot of air in it, I
wonder if it had so much that it meant all of the walls holding in the bubbles were extra thin
It's far from done moving, but it didn't grow very much
I think I'm gonna kill this
I've killed the vacuum for the moment, and I want to try this same experiment in the smaller chamber, because it pulls the air out
of that much faster. I think we'll have better luck getting our meringue to reduce back down to egg white in there
Here goes, 3, 2, 1
Yeah, it just starts growing so much faster in this chamber. It just sort of tears itself apart. I
don't think it's expanding, it just has air trapped underneath it, and so it's just lifting the whole blob at once
Okay let's try adding the pressure back
That to me looks- I mean it's the same color as the egg white
The
whiter parts here floating around, I think they're that little tail that attaches the yolk
to the egg white. We had some of that floating around in there I think it's just a little bit more liquid because we've beaten
it half to death with a beater. It doesn't really have any of the connections holding it together
that it did before. It's kind of return to an egg white state. Not bad
Well there you have it, whipped cream and whipped egg whites in a vacuum chamber
We pull out all of the air, and they kind of return to their un-whipped state
The egg whites have a very different texture, and I think that's because
we broke up the bonds that were holding together the albumin with our egg beater
But the whipped cream actually seemed to return to about how it started, which I thought was pretty cool
Thank you Matthew DeRossett for your idea. Check your YouTube inbox, we're sending you 25 bucks. If you've got any ideas of things you
want to see us try on the show, let us know down in the comments. If we use your idea, we'll send you $25
Thanks guys for joining us for this video and remember to come gear yourself up with products and merch at thekingofrandom.com
See you there.
New experiment. We get a box. It goes around my arm and the bowl, and we fill it with helium. It's airtight mold box
Fill it with helium, and then we whip it so that it's full of helium and not air and we make a meringue that literally
floats, and it floats- it's not going to work guys, don't- they won't
I'm going to crack one egg and then I'm going
to put a whole egg in the vacuum chamber, I'll pull a vacuum and we'll see if anything happens to either of them
And now quite a few bubbles inside the egg mixture are expanding out.
Ooh~
delightful
What's up guys, Grant here. I'm just working behind the scenes on some important stuff. Keep supporting Nate, he's the man and he's bringing back
all the diy that you've been asking for